Have you ever read an anime description for a show you just watched and you're just like-
MAN
THIS IS
This is nothing like what the show is actually about
Yeah. Most of the descriptions I find don't really contain the information we need
Either they oversell something or undersell something
or aren't really indicative to the watching experience of the anime
So, I thought I'd play a fun game with myself and see if I could fix some anime descriptions
to contain the information that we really need to know
Alright, so let's start off with something I'm sure we can all agree with
you know, something very...
very simple you know
easy quick fix
Boku no Pico
STOP RECOMMENDING THIS ANIME TO PEOPLE YOU PIECES OF SHI--
but actucally watch it tho ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
Battle Royal
Diary game
Predicting the future
Ok, you get the point
But see, this is the perfect example of a description that desperatly needs fixing
It's too tame
It makes it sound way more complex than it actually is
and it doesn't even mention the entire reason it got so popular
let's be real about this
Yeah I think...
I think that should about do it
POKEMON
Alright this should be pretty easy
I mean everyone grew up with this
OH GOD
Jesus Wikipedia! Do we really need a page worth of plot summary to explain Pokemon
It's really not that complicated
Look, let me cut out some of this fat for you
mmh mmh
Jojo's Bizarre Adventure
Now, how do we even begin to describe this anime?
Well, actually, it's pretty simple
but we're not going to give the series much justice with this description
Look, if it's Jojo's
There is only one real way to describe it
Ok well:
YEAH!!!!!!!!!!!!!!!
We all know the reason we watched High School of the Dead
HAHA! YEAH BABY!
YOU KNOW THE DEAL
So, why the hell is there no mention of this in any description anywhere?
ANYWHERE!
MONSTERS?!?!
HIGH SCHOOL?!?!
C'mon guys we can do better than this!
C'mon Crunchyroll
I know you can do better than this
I mean I know Onizuka is a feel good show and whatnot
And sure: He's crude and fooled-mouthed
but "Using his street smarts to deal with colleagues and students"?
Let's not undersell here!
Remember kids!
If in doubt:
Just be a Dickhead™
PFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFFF
Who cares about that?
How are we ever going to appeal to the millenials of this age
If we don't spice this up a bit
(In echo) IT WAS JUST A PRANK BRO!
PS: Use coupon code: "Geass" for 10% off your next meal at Pizza Hut™
Alright ONE PUNCH MAN
With a title like: ONE PUNCH MAN
It should be pretty simple to describe what ONE PUNCH MAN is about Right?
So WHY THE HELL DO WE NEED ALL THIS?
Don't worry tho
I got you covered
LOOK GUYS IT'S ANIME ABOUT SWIMMING
SWIMMING
SWIMMAAAAAAANG!
I'm kidding guys. Let's be real here. This show has nothing to do with swimming
Alright! You know what? I've had enough of doing this the long way
Let's just go to the LIGHTNING ROUND!
Spice and Wolf
School Days
Zankyou No Terror
Death Note
Tokyo Ghoul
Steins;Gate
Hetalia
Angel Beats
And that's all we had time for today
Next time: We'll be giving accurate descriptions of some of your favourite Shitty Waifus™
So, if you want to join in on that:
Leave me your accurate descriptions of some of your Shitty Waifus™
Here: let me get us started!
Senjougahara
*Music Play*
Hey guys! Hope you enjoyed the video
Thank you very much this month to:
And everyone else supporting me on Patreon
for making this video possible
This was just a dumb little video I came up with
to reuse some of the plot descriptions I wrote
for reviews that were never finished over the years
As I'm spending most of my time working on Anime 2016 this month
If you'd like seeing more of my stuff
You can click on the annotation on this video
And you can also follow me on Facebook and Twitter too
Anyway that's it for me
I've been Gigguk and I'll see you all next time